uno de los comandantes de una de las
brigadas en esta región de la provincia
de donde es que como el resto de los
militares ucranianos no hablan o no dan
detalles sobre Esa llamada
contraofensiva que estarían planeando
las tropas ucranianas en los próximos
días y semanas decía hace poco que no se
podía esperar una batalla como la de la
Segunda Guerra Mundial en las que dos
tropas estaban enfrentadas Y listas para
atacarse una a otra que esto se iba a
dar poco a poco y en diferentes frentes
y muchos ucranianos empiezan a entender
que posiblemente Esto es lo que está
sucediendo en estos últimos días donde
todo parece acelerarse en la noche de
ayer hubo nuevos ataques con misiles y
drones kamikasis no solamente sobre la
ciudad de kiev sino también sobre la
ciudad de Odessa la mayoría de ellos
fueron interceptados por la defensa
aérea Pero al menos tres cayeron en lo
que ellos llaman instituciones escolares
sin haber dado mayores detalles y
también se une este ataque masivo ayer a
la ciudad de gersón que siguió en la
madrugada de hoy al menos 23 personas
han fallecido en esa ciudad que
recordemos fue la única capital de
provincia en caer en control Ruso y fue
liberada a finales de noviembre desde
entonces es atacada constantemente por
las tropas rusas que están al otro lado
del Río La ciudad de gelson está llamado
un toque de queda de 56 horas que
empezará esta noche y muchos se
preguntan esto a qué se debe tiene que
ver relacionado con la seguridad de esta
ciudad o también con una posible
contraofensiva en esa zona ya cuando
otras contras se dieron como en o
también ejerzo mandaron a la población a
quedarse en su casa por varios días como
está llamada así la ciudad de gersón en
los próximos días y también esos ataques
continúan en otras partes del país
estamos en Constantinopla en las
cercanías que ha sido atacada
constantemente desde ayer al igual que
gramators donde dormimos que fue atacada
nuevamente durante la noche